[Music]
okay so this is my review
of episode six of wanda vision all new
halloween spooktacular now from the
promos of this episode
this was the episode i was most excited
for when we get to the halloween and the
90s
being a 90s kid being halloween my
favorite episode
i was really excited for this and what
was really great about this episode
is knowing that there's nine episodes in
this season this
is a really effective transitional
episode to
push us into the final act here going
now
into the final three episodes starting
next week what's also interesting
is this was an episode where there was a
lot of promo
footage we saw of this episode and all
the prior episodes too
but now we're gonna go into the
territory of stuff we haven't seen in
promos there's kind of this
blank slate now of we don't even know
what to expect
coming up now so it's gonna be a really
exciting final stretch
but having said that what really
impressed me about this episode
is that the halloween episode was
probably the most shown footage
in promos for this show but somehow they
masked the kids being in it
quicksilver being in it they really kept
things under wraps so well
and they really nailed this malcolm in
the middle feel
all these 90s type shows with the intro
here i always applaud the humor and how
well they write the music for it but
just the amount of detail put into it
that extra effort to really nail this
and
they nailed that 90s feel with breaking
the fourth wall
with billy here and that classic humor
where
someone brings up a memory and then they
cut to that memory and come back
when evan peters is actually bringing up
when they were trick-or-treating his
kids
and evan peters is the perfect actor to
pull off
this type of vibe especially because
he's so good at really fast witty
dialogue and
you got to just give him props because
he's just really nailing it here in this
episode and it makes you so happy they
went with him as
quicksilver it's also crazy because i
just realized in this episode not the
last episode that
billy here is played by young luke from
haunting of hill house
awesome to always see anyone from
haunting a phil i'll show up in anything
so that excited me but what's
really stood out to me is how well this
show has pulled off
telling its main story through different
vehicles
each episode where it's a different
decade a different type of format of
show they have to do it through
while making that accurate giving easter
eggs and also pushing the plot forward
and making interesting and it's really
stood out how effective they've been
doing that especially in the last two
episodes where
like i said they're doing a good job at
blending what's going on with sword
and then cutting to what's going on with
westview why this episode's such an
effective transitional episode is
because
by the end of it it's bringing those two
factions of sword and westview our two
settings together to set up for that
final act of the last three so you knew
it was coming with wanda and vision we'd
see their
comic outfits be their halloween
costumes but it was really cool to see
the kids have theirs
being that billy and tommy are dressed
really as their younger avengers
counterparts
and that we get to see quicksilver here
in his costume they do a great job of
revealing the twins powers
tommy's got quicksilver super speed
powers and then later on
that billy has powers like his mother
they also drop in lines that are really
gonna
just feed people's theories even more
now that
there's this villain who's the devil
here and people think it's
dottie and what feeds that theory is
this big line quicksilver says really
quick where he's like
unleash hell demons spawn to the kids so
that's really making you think now there
is this
bigger villain behind all of this and
that it's probably the devil there's
also some really effective seriously
creepy moments
and i loved in particular when vision
was first doing his neighborhood watch
and he notices that woman
hanging up halloween decorations outside
she's just going like this i love that
the director side to hang on that shot
because that's what made it creepy
because it just kept going and she's
crying
really eerie and it goes to vision now
seeing all these people
at the edge of west view now just
stopped they're not
moving and it has that westworld feel to
it
leading to a great scene where he finds
agnes now
now remember a lot of people think agnes
is the character from the comics agatha
who's a witch who kind of
shows scarlet witch her powers but look
she's dressed like a witch
she's got the gray hair it might be a
red herring but it's interesting they
let her do that
which like laugh in her not brainwashed
state so i really do believe
we'll see that she was the one kind of
helping scarlet witch learn more about
how powerful she actually is and that
she probably is a victim too but was
kind of part of this mess that got her
and wanda in this trap whoever the big
power is using wanda's big power or
maybe just
influencing her that's what's so
effective too you're constantly
wondering like
how much of an antagonist is wanda in
this show in this story because we see
at the end she uses her powers
to bring that hex further but who was
really the influence behind her is
someone influencing her mind
don't really fully know they do a good
job of keeping mystery throughout while
they're still giving us answers
and the tone here there's still so much
creepy stuff going on
this 90s kids commercial which really
nails
those type of commercials are all over
the place watching that as kids
and it's this yogurt commercial for yo
magic and also this big moment where
like when wanda saw vision in this dead
body
version it was even scarier seeing
pietro in his
the body that was killed by ultron and
that she's just
using a dead corpse that she's actually
talking to but the big plunge to move
the plot forward is getting
vision to step out of west view him
learning more from agnes
it's interesting he doesn't know
obviously about what happened before his
death that he was even an avenger
but he does have enough information to
kind of attach us to vision now as a
protagonist
to kind of help wanda through this but
he hits a wall he can't get out of
westview because that's what's keeping
him alive
and it's a great catalyst to get wanda
to snap here
also great catalyst for us to reveal
billy's powers that he can hear
vision and what's going on with him and
this great cliffhanger of wanda now
we're fully seeing how powerful scarlet
witch is and she just
extends the hex bringing darcy in which
again is so interesting because now
we're gonna see next episode darcy
in some kind of odd state and how
fitting it is that sword becomes a
circus
the only thing that hurt this episode a
little bit it wasn't the best stuff here
with
wu monica and darcy combatting with
hayward hayward's clearly a villain here
now which was
already set up last episode but he's
fully going in that way
there's a lot of hand-holding here
they're given a lot of exposition
through darcy
a lot of convenience to how they're
finding information how quickly she's
able to hack through things
and explain things she's kind of
becoming a plotbot and i wasn't crazy
about
especially the moment when wu and monica
just take down those henchmen really
quick and throw them in a van
it was like okay that was pretty trophy
but wasn't the best on the sword side
for sure but i'm happy that like i said
they're bringing that now together
bringing
that setting to our setting of the hex
bringing them in it's gonna be just to
see if monica and wu
actually got sucked in i don't think
they did i think they're probably gonna
get away
and they kind of left the cliffhanger
seeing if hayward got away so that's
gonna be interesting but again it's
bringing now
us into this final act we're gonna have
now some serious conflict it leaves you
so excited for the next episode it's
this big mystery but
i do have a feeling by the end of all
this we're gonna get
probably a full episode of what went on
in the past with wanda
following vision's death and how this
all began i really dug this episode i'm
giving it a 9.4
still excellent i'm still blown away how
good this show has just been on this
role since
episode four so like four five six it's
now just
rolling here and it just leaves you more
and more excited each week i love the
week-to-week format
it just shows you how effective still
water cooler talk is if this was just
bingeable
in one sitting it would have happened
weeks ago and been over with and then
people were like
when's the next marvel show like no i
like that they're making each episode
this big event it makes it that much
more exciting
call me old school call me old-fashioned
but there's a lot of downside
to that netflix type show of binging
where it's just like junk food you just
swallow it you're done you can't just
savor it and you can really appreciate
what's going on week to week i'm not
just saying that because it helps
my format of doing week tweak reviews
but i always
always prefer it because i love
discussing things with people in theory
so
it makes it that much more fun but yes
i'm giving this a 9.4 let me know what
you guys thought of wanda vision
down below episode six i'd really like
to hear your theories as well
every thought you have let's just get
the discussion going
please check out my other reviews i do
of serving right now your honor
i'll be doing more shows and movies
coming out i also do celebrity
interviews you're gonna check those out
if you really like what i do here please
subscribe it helps me in so many ways
you have no idea and if you
love what i do here will help me to do
more reviews and videos for you guys
and do this full time it's just a two
dollar monthly donation you can commit
to it's a paypal link
i would really appreciate that it's
linked down below and please follow me
at stevenshow on twitter instagram for
more of me
and i'll see you next time